that is gentlemen two years ago a superb
artists and great lady came from
Broadway to make her oscar-winning
picture debut tonight she's in
Philadelphia preparing a new play for
Broadway we take you now to Philadelphia
and Miss Shirley booth
hello there we here in Philadelphia at
the forest theater by the beautiful sea
are feeling the waves of excitement that
are coming from Hollywood and we're
waiting all of us the cast the entire
fan of staff all of us are waiting with
bated breath to hear the name of the
winner for the award tonight for the
leading male performance as you know we
have nominated Richard Burton in the
robe 20th Century Fox Montgomery Clift
and From Here to Eternity Columbia
Pictures William Holden in Stalag 17
Paramount Pictures Burt Lancaster in
From Here to Eternity Columbia Pictures
Marlon Brando for his performance in
Julius Caesar MGM and now for the winner
Donald yes surely yeah a little Khanna
yes your only buddy would you mind
opening that envelope for me yeah we'll
pick up the phone we have a line right
through to you Oh fine yeah give me yes
oh hey let's not keep waiting anymore
yes yes
Oh fine Thank You Donald I'll tell
everyone yes ladies and gentlemen the
winner is William Holden
Thank You mr. Harlan ladies and
gentlemen
you